[Music]
congratulations this show has just
exploded it's become so insanely popular
i know who knew it's crazy and and and
then you start
there's a lot of press about the show
now you read about stuff that's going on
in the press and i was reading the other
day and i don't know if this is true it
just sounded funny that the human
cast and the zombie cast don't eat
together
that which just seemed like a crazy
like no zombies at our table this is
when you're shooting the show
zombies have to sit at one table and the
humans sit at another table it wasn't
like that all the way from the beginning
but then um when you're sitting across
from a zombie and you're eating chicken
and then pieces of prosthetic fallen
play and look like chicken and it just i
think starts to enough people so yeah
you don't want to eat with a zombie
basically right because their like cheek
falls off yeah and then he's like ah
yes yeah and then you just think about
death
one other thing is that the fans of the
show really pay attention to everything
and one of the things that's kind of
funny is that uh in some of the recent
episodes
uh the characters in this reality in the
reality of the show the zombie
apocalypse has happened it happened a
while ago it's been maybe over a year
and the characters running around and
they'll run past a nicely manicured lawn
and it's got people on the internet
saying
the zombies are like mowing their lawns
yeah they're keeping up appearances we
have actually signs in scenario which is
where we shoot that's where sonoya is in
georgia in georgia that's where you
shoot it yeah yeah and we have a little
sign saying dear citizens of scenario
please remember we are shooting in a
apocalyptic show here so don't mow your
lips so don't mow your lawns but it
doesn't always get remembered
so you get mad when someone actually
i would think most most people i know i
would be so thrilled to live in a world
where i'm not allowed to mow the lawn
yeah yeah you let it go to crap and it's
yeah you can't do it honey zombie
apocalypse uh
you um as we just saw in that scene
uh a lot of zombie killing
and you really seem to i mean
you're a terrific actor but do you enjoy
i mean you're you really get intense
killing zombies you have a good what's
called a good kill face good bloodlust
kill face okay yeah yeah well just when
you're into it we had i saw still
earlier i think we have it here uh
somewhere of you look at that
that is incredibly fierce
that's fantastic yeah that's my hottest
moment yeah
no it's funny because we have uh i mean
that looks so intense and then you have
to kind of be careful and you don't want
to hurt people so we have some weapons
that are
lined with rubber so we'll run around
with a real weapon yeah in case we fall
on it that's fine but then if we when
we're working with the extras we
actually don't want to hit them so we
have these big huge knives lined in
rubber and you have to sell it with your
face so you have to really make it look
like it's you know but then when you do
it the last wow that was good yeah do
that again that was fantastic huh i need
a pencil you need oh this is you killing
me with a pencil this is what i want to
see it's like nothing right right but
then when you see the face then
oh you got to go that way do it that's a
camera just give me a really good one
right there yeah that wasn't i didn't
even scare myself no
mine would be like this it'd be like
[Applause]
that would be me just
yeah i'd be sort of tentative about it
yeah i'm gonna no maybe okay maybe i'm
gonna kill you somewhere else we'll see
maybe not now i'm just going to erase
you